>> Greg: HERE WE ARE.
THE HEAD IS MADE OF CHEESE.
RON IS ON A ROLL ACCORDING TO
THE NEW WISCONSIN POLE.
A STRAW POLL NOW MADE WITH REAL
STRAW, I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHY I
LEFT THAT IN THERE.
AND FLORIDA GOVERNOR I HAD OF
DONALD TRUMP IS THE GOP FRONT
RUNNER IN 2024.
WE WILL NOTE THE MINUTE HE'S
TAKEN SERIOUSLY WHEN THEY LABEL
HIM A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
CONDUCTED OVER THE WEEKEND AT
THE WISCONSIN REPUBLICAN
CONVENTION, ATTENDEES WERE ASKE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THOUSANDS OF
POTENTIAL CANDIDATES FOR
PRESIDENT AS WELL AS A VARIETY
OF HOMEGROWN CHEESES 38% OF
VOTERS CHOSE DESANTIS AS OPPOSE
TO TRUMP.
THIS IS JUST ONE OF MANY RECENT
POLLS ECHOING A BROADER
SENTIMENT THAT GOVERNOR DESANTI
PROPERTY D-LETTER IS GROWING
FASTER THAN DUCTLESS MARIE'S
BICEPS.
DID I NOT TELL YOU THE BLOOD
WOULD WORK?
IF TRUMP DECIDES TO RUN AGAIN,
HE MIGHT HAVE ITS WORK CUT OUT
FOR HIM AT THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY, BUT BEFORE WE TRY ANY
CONCLUSIONS, THE POLE COMPRISED
OF THREE TO 25 PEOPLE THAT'S
SMALLER THAN OTHER STRAW POLLS
BUT LARGER THAN THE AUDIENCE FO
THE DAILY SHOW.
KELLYANNE, THIS IS INTERESTING
I'M NOT GOING TO TELL YOU WHAT
THINK.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS.
>> I THINK THAT RON DESANTIS HA
BEEN AN EXCELLENT GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA AND HE HAS MADE NATIONA
NEWS ON MANY NUMBER OF FRONTS.
I WAS THERE ONE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS CAMPAIGNING FOR RONDO'S AND
ANY HELP THEM IN THE PRIMARY AN
WE ALMOST HAD ANDREW GUILLEN WH
CAME UP, GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA.
AND, LOOK, I THINK THAT RESULTS
PRODUCE CONSEQUENCES AND THAT I
WHY THERE IS A BUZZER FROM
GOVERNOR DESANTIS.
HE HAS RAISED $100 BILLION.
ON THE STRAW POLL I THINK THAT
PEOPLE LIKE TO MAKE A BIG DEAL
OUT OF TRUMP'S ENDORSEMENT.
325 PEOPLE WERE AT MY WEDDING.
>> Greg: I WASN'T INVITED.
EXPECTS BETTER LUCK NEXT TIME.
HOW DID BEAUFORT DO THE POLE?
I THINK --
HE WOULD LOVE TO RUN IN 2024 FO
TWO MAKE RECENT.
NUMBER ONE, THERE'S SO MUCH
UNFINISHED BUSINESS THAT HE
WANTED TO TAP INTO INTERN NUMBE
RUNNING THIS COUNTRY ON SPITE.
HE SEES LIKE WE ALL DO THAT
PEOPLE ARE HURTING THE INFANTS
CAN'T GET A B FORMULA AND PEOPL
ARE DYING OF DRUG OVERDOSES.
FOOD AND IS IN UKRAINE.
IT JUST ALL WENT TO.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT --
THE DONORS ARE VERY HOT DOG
DESANTIS PICKETT BY WORLD BRAND
IS THAT THAT THIS, I WOULD SAY
PLEASE QUIT SAYING MY NAME.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW THERE WAS
RESEARCH ABOUT A LOT OF AIRLINE
DISASTERS AND SOUTH KOREA AND I
WAS BECAUSE OF THE ASSISTANT
CAPTAIN, THE COPILOT WOULDN'T
SAY WHEN THEY MADE A MISTAKE SO
THEY SWITCH THEM AND THEY MADE
THE COPILOT THE PILOTS OF THE
PERSON WITH MORE SENIORITY WAS
THE COPILOT WHO WOULD TELL THE
OTHER GUY WHAT TO DO.
MY THEORY IS WOULDN'T IT BE
GREAT IF DISSENT IS FOOD RUN
WITH TRUMP AS VP.
MIND BLOWING, RIGHT.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
ABOUT SELF DRIVING CARS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND YOU,.
BACK.
>> YOU HAVE A GUY WHO HAS BEEN
THERE WHO SAYS THIS IS WHAT YOU
SHOULD DO.
IS LIKE HE HAS THIS PROTÉGÉ.
>> TRUMP IS THE LEADER OF THE
AMERICA FIRST MOVEMENT AND WE
DON'T THINK OF HIM AS A NUMBER 2
.
>> TRUMP WOULD LIKE TO BE VICE
PRESIDENT, DO YOU REALLY THINK
THAT?
YOU REALLY SEE A SITUATION WHER
HE IS LIKE I PUT LIKE TO REPLACE
, LET HARRIS.
>> Greg: HOW MUCH FUN WITH
TRUMP AS VP BE.
>> OH, SURE.
HILARIOUS.
HE WOULD DO WHATEVER HE WANTS.
HE WOULD BE GREAT LET'S TRADE L
eBRON JAMES FOR SUPER BOWL
PLAYERS FOR 50 BUCKS.
FANTASY POLITICS PLEASE.
SO YOU THINK IT'S A IDEA.
>> I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
LOGIC.
BEFORE.
>> Greg: DON'T EXPECT LOGIC
FROM ME.
>> ADDRESS BUT I JUST SAID,
TRANSLATE.
TELL ME WHAT I MEANT SAP
RESPECTS YOU SAID WHAT YOU MEAN
TO SAY.
IT IS JUST WRONG.
>> THESE ARE BAD REVIEWS ON YOU
BANNED LIST.
EXPECTS IT DOESN'T NEED TO BE
THAT OF THE PEP OR JUST DO
WHATEVER HE WANTS.
HE WAS THE PRESIDENT AND DID
I FIND THE POLE A BIG OLD SNEEZE
.
WE'VE GOT TO .5 YEARS LEFT OF
JOE BIDEN AND IT IS LIKE GETTIN
EVERYBODY'S HOPES UP.
'S BEFORE WE ARE NOT EVEN
HALFWAY THROUGH THIS MISS WE
HAVE TO CLAW OUR WAY THROUGH
THIS.
THAT STRUCK A NERVE.
EITHER THAT OF THE CAFETERIA
FOOD WE FED THEM FINALLY HIT
THEM.
>> TRUMP IS VICE PRESIDENT IDEA
IS THE WORST THING TO FOCUS ON.
>> Greg: WAS TRYING TO MAKE
THIS INTERESTING, GUYS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE LEADE
OF THE AMERICA FIRST MOVEMENT.
AND IT IS FASCINATED FASCINATIN
THAT WE ARE SITTING HERE
DEBATING TWO OF THE STRONG
POLITICIANS ON THE RIGHT AND YO
CAN'T FIND ONE, AND THAT'S NOT
PARTISANSHIP, THAT'S A FACT, YO
CAN'T FIND ONE ON THE LEFT.
>> Greg: HERE IS MY NEXT
THEORY, AMERICA'S SECOND.
YOU COULD HELP THE OTHER COUNTR
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW --
KEEP GOING.
CANADA FIRST, AMERICA